even hi just name you're like
why are you just calling my name do you
feel like guys like do you do you feel
like guys like the girls that like them
you think that's a true statement no
yeah no no
they don't know
i would say they like to be violated
small small wait do you like to be
violated guys
let me explain i don't explain it
but is this like
if you show that you don't want them
like that
then they're gonna keep persevering to
but that's not true what what what do
you mean it depends if i wanted you in
the first place yeah but if i know you
want me okay but i'm like um that might
be age specific i won't lie because if a
woman should if a woman's showing me
nothing i'm not going anywhere that
might be a beta man mentality
it's a reason
i'm sorry
because because the alpha alpha me i
can't even hang on i can't believe i'm
saying i know i hate it i hate that term
god i
oh but the the alpha man
he
he knows what he wants so if you act
like you don't want him like okay cool
if you like a girl and she acts super
interested is does that ever turn you
off no okay yeah that's that's what i
mean no if you like a girl and she acts
stupid and she and she acts like she's
interested doesn't turn me off at all
it's a level of maturity yeah if you're
a child i want i want to see you
like me
i want to see that as a matter yeah i
want to know that you like me
if you're going to run then run i'm
going like you're going to be running by
yourself yeah but that's maturity like
certain guys they they have about i'm
going to chase you
i don't chase
i i chase in the beginning if i see
something i like i'll chase it if i see
that you don't want me to chase you i'll
be gone
i think that's what most people though
oh yeah
i don't don't chase and be like
no
i just feel like once um once a girl has
been chased
and she actually starts to show the
interest
then he's like
i can move on to the next is there
anything to that sarah or did he catch
you and maybe he depends on what he
wanted if he wanted to just have sex
with you then yeah yeah he got what he
wanted yeah but it's not there's imagine
there's no sex he's like he's chasing
her he's trying to talk to her he's
doing whatever he gets her she starts
she finally starts to talk and then
kabum he's like maybe he wanted to show
himself that he could still chase
but he could still get girls it shows
that women just basically get used
i mean that's not you yeah he didn't get
set he didn't have sex she's what used
to feed his ego i think yeah
then women do the same when they go on
dates with men that they absolutely know
they're not going to date again no i
wouldn't go on a man that i wouldn't
want to date but but girls do no girls
gotta get three meals nowadays
that's a bit crazy it's not it's not an
anomaly it's like 56 of women when
surveyed admitted to it yeah i feel like
we have this whole i say like disposable
culture like literally you could just
toss anyone about like oh i'll talk to
you today tomorrow no
so i think that whole everything is in
demand plays into fact like you can go
in an app and get 10 girls today
and then i can download it right now and
get vagina in half an hour
so that's the problem like back in the
days you actually have to
meet someone in an establishment or a
friend of a friend
mom dad someone someone's gonna
introduce you to someone whereas now
yeah but what are you looking for that's
the real question
are you looking for a hook up or are you
looking for a relationship are you
looking for marriage are you looking for
something serious do you get what i mean
so if you're in an arena with guys who
are looking for a hookup and you're
looking for marriage it's not going to
work is it and then if you're going for
girls who are looking for a hook up and
they're going to hit you up just to go
on a date to have a meal that's a bit
mad you can kind of tell when a woman
doesn't like you and she's just there
for the meal but then it's kind of like
a pat on your back um a lot of girls
know how to act on a date like
everything's cool you know what i'm
saying like
they can act like everything's cool when
they're nice and then
they won't see yeah tomorrow they won't
if you won't even hear from them but i
think a lot of guys have that
understanding when they go out that
they're gonna blow so much cash on a
girl i don't know okay maybe type of
woman why not type of woman i might not
even know you in this is what you think
is me right
i said you're talking to a man who was
in like a relationship for 10 years i am
very well versed in grand gestures i
know what a grand gesture is to my woman
i'll take you on a holiday i will
buy you things valentine's day birthday
i was very well versed in it i'm coming
from that and i'm coming into a
marketplace where women want grand
gestures and i've just met you are you
crazy my woman got grand gestures
i don't know you
let's go for a picnic in a park and i'll
have a talk with you do you know what i
mean i'll see you let's go for a coffee
and then and i'll see what's going on
don't ask me for don't ask me to spend
two three four hundred pound in a
restaurant at hackathon i don't know you
yeah but you see sorry to her but like
i like the grand gestures however i
don't expect it from you if i say let's
go somewhere nice best believe i'm ready
to put in
there what do you mean we haven't got
time many of you got time for what you
want to pay for me on a first date no no
no no not pay for you oh okay we all put
in every like let's go somewhere nice
and enjoy the food because i'm sorry
like i don't want to say i'm a bit
boujee but i'm a bit [ __ ] bougie and
i don't i don't like
i i can do picnic in the park
give me m s yes i'll do picnic in the
past in the park
i will provide the m s because that's
and she knows that's that's just what
i'm like i don't care like i don't i'm
not bothered about what you have what
you don't have like as long as
i'm happy in this like then i'm cool you
need to be by yourself
piss off like you do you need to be by
yourself
myself that's what i'm saying but you
need to be by yourself like you're
you're acting like the man in this no
i'm not acting like that man i don't
think i'm acting like the man i just i'm
not gonna settle for
bs because someone doesn't want to give
it to me
like give it to you what obligations do
they have to have it you don't have an
obligation to give it to me but if you
want something from me you're gonna have
to show me
that
i'm i'm actually worth you even getting
that okay well what are you showing to
him what am i sure yeah like what are
you what are you chasing
i'm a very intelligent woman i'm very
caring i can be very submissive it's
just that you you can be submissive
it's it's a choice i can every woman has
not
i'm not going to submit to every man
that i meet no no no no submission
should be your default setting your
energy when it comes to men yeah but you
can you can't because
all right if i said as a man i will
only be masculine for the right woman
so
exactly right exactly but that's how it
sounds to men when you say i can be
feminine or i can't be submissive
they're like oh i don't want to deal
with that headache i'll just find a girl
who who is submissive
but like that sometimes just because
if i ask a guy to do something for me
why is it taking you 10 years right done
like today i've asked you the nicest way
possible cherry on top everything but
it's taking you 10 years now i have to
take it to my own initiative to do it on
my own yeah so when you keep doing that
when you have to keep doing certain
things by yourself you will have that
mindset of
i will choose to when i will choose when
to be submissive if but
like i don't know the guys that you're
around like i said i'm i'm a little bit
older like i don't know but
like i said all i'm saying is
the expectation of a lot of
women
wanting certain things when i know as a
man what i can provide and what i have
provided in the past
i'm just like you're not you're not you
don't deserve that well i'll give you an
exam my dad's a one percent guy so in
top income earners he had one percent he
had 10 kids with my mom and if my mom
demanded these ex yeah
he so he's one percent earners like he
he's a multimedia yeah yeah he owns a
software company he's
a lot of like women
would have overlooked him because
a lot of wealthy successful men aren't
trying to spend money like that my dad
is cheap yeah
he's not he's not going to spend a bunch
of money on a [ __ ]
like i'm sorry he doesn't know you
and so and so then you're going to put
yourself as too high you're going to put
yourself like in okay like and same with
my brothers all every single person in
my family makes six figures that is
older than me so all of my brothers
they're engineers they're successful
they are tall they are good looking they
are there are a lot of things that women
want and if and i'm telling you if they
heard oh i need to take you on a nice
date or we'll split it we have to go
here because you're making it about you
and so they're going to overlook you
because they're like well that just
sounds like a headache yeah like i'm
going to take the nice like the nice
girl that wants to get coffee because
she wants to get to know me exactly
because the date is about a date right
in my principle it's about getting to
know one another we can get to know each
other we don't have to have a nice
restaurant to get to know each other i
want to get to know you want to get to
know me we can do that in a setting
that's nice it doesn't have to be
sparkly and with you know diamonds and
crystals and all that kind of stuff
i wasn't talking about the hackathons
though notice i said we can go to a
picnic in the park but i just like mns
that's just me personally as a person so
at the end of the day like this is fine
even down to like when i have been
online and i've seen these weird men
that want to be doing up oh i'll take
you to this place i'll take you to that
place i find it unattractive i find it
scary i feel like you're trying to lure
me into something that's not real and
then you know what's the scary part i
have met
and i'm sorry to make this personal
but i have met somebody
online thank god i didn't meet them in
person who ended up being an actual
convicted sexual offender thank god i
didn't fall for the glitz and the glam
that he was trying to
throw at me because imagine if i did
what would have happened then
it would have got scary
and also too another thing that i've
noticed
especially like
from
mid-20s going to like yeah mid to late
20s is a lot of guys are becoming lazy
and the reason why i say that is because
i don't know if it's because you can get
access to so many women or
um just get access to anything
the
willing to push to like actually put
effort to meeting someone or like
actually come up with an idea
be proactive
it's because okay i'll tell you there's
two reasons one it's the 20 80 rule so
80 of women are
20 of men have access to 80 of women
because if you ask 80 of women what they
want in a man they list 20 percent of
men
so we're all going after the same guys
so it's just supply and demand those
guys can get a lot of girls a lot of
proactive men are now disappearing a lot
of white proactive
do you know i'm a pro i want to call
myself a proactive man but i'm
when i'm proactive
that's just my default position
like some people's default position is
not proactiveness
do you know what i mean like some people
are
dtf
do you know what i mean like
just down to [ __ ] like it's like oh
that's dude they're not trying to go on
days they're not trying to do all of
that but that's what i said earlier you
know you have to discern who what type
of person are you
do you get what i mean you you're
looking at the uh the man but you have
to take accountability for yourself
first and then put forward your best
self i think that's what's happening now
like a lot of those are getting confused
that's right and then with and also with
the men that you're attracting you have
you know if you are attracting the same
type of guy in
the same type of guy in different bodies
what is it that you're putting forth
that's allowing these
those men to be in your space
um
um having high demands of men that
clearly can't perform to that level it's
like a losing battle do you get what i
mean so
it's good to have expectation obviously
you have standards but are your
standards realistic
do you get what i mean as as a woman i
know i can't go to a place where there's
millionaires and be like yeah i'm
demanding this this in this knowing that
i personally i'm not up to par you know
so it's a counter can you imagine
wanting princess behavior or or
demanding princess behavior and you're
not my princess
like
it doesn't make no sense like you're
asking men that you have no idea about
you don't know the i'm not saying you
ladies but i'm saying ladies in
gentlemen they're asking men to treat
them like a quote-unquote princess
you are not my princess
what obligation do i have to treat you
like my princess i'll treat you like an
individual and a person with respect but
you're not getting all the glitz and
glamour yet that's that that's earned
yeah but that's why you need to ask
sorry to cut you but that's why you need
to ask questions you need to be
inquisitive and understand the person's
core values do they align with your core
values what's the point of being treated
like a princess if that's a temporary
day out it's not realistic do you get
what i mean
if you're talking i'm gone
no problem
hey
because there are
i think now there is this big
disillusion of
ah another thing
some women
if something happens to them once like a
guy buys her a bunch of flowers 80 flat
80 roses she automatically not all of
them but quite a few automatically
believe
everybody
like flowers i'm thinking sometime some
and then when i do talk to like younger
guys i'm like you be careful what you do
because if you do it once best believe
she's going to ask you to do it again so
if you're going to do her nails for her
once
she's going out
she's going to expect you to do it again